we are here with sharon shooter the
founder of amma beauty
a company that i have been a huge fan of
for
a really long time i can't believe i'm
doing the show with you sharon and we
have
another connection which was that i was
lucky enough to participate in your
pull-up for change and yes you did
thank you uh for allowing me to that
party everybody jumped on board because
your mission was so clear
why did you start the pull-up for change
yes i did that really to drive or raise
more awareness so shine more light to
the lack of economic opportunities for
the black community
um especially within the beauty space i
know we've been talking about lack of
inclusivity
but it was really to shine light at some
of the root causes of this because
really it's like it's like a computer
right whatever you put in is what's
going to come out and so
for me that was really the driver to
make sure that we have a better world
where we have
more economic equality because the
economic inequality in america right now
is at pandemic level so
thank you for participating and pulling
up were you always such an activist
because your activism is so strong and
powerful and a real game changer in the
industry now
were you always that person or did you
have a title wave of inspiration
well for me i've always been the person
who speaks up you know in my country
with kody sorosoki right speak louder
so i've always been that troublemaker as
a kid i get beat up all the time so
i think from mine i didn't even know
there was a word for it it's just
whenever i see something
that needs to change i don't have any me
to just sit it out and i think
as as people and especially as artists
as business people
we have everything we do have to be
connected to the times that we live in
and right now we live in times of growth
and justice so for me it would be just
odd just going about you know selling
lipsticks and eyeliners
and yeah people are dying and starving
and you know
there's injustice and it's like oh who
cares i just want to wear makeup you
know so uh
so i think that there was no option you
know sharon i feel the exact same way i
try to be so positive on this show but i
want to talk about the pain
and the reality and the world we are
living in
and unless i'm living in reality then i
don't feel like i have the right to be
positive so i really understand that
fight
and um 2020 in my opinion has been one
of the most important years in history
period yes and i'm honored to be a part
of it and have been woken up and learned
and everything that you've done for it
and on a completely
beauty junkie level that has nothing to
do with the
crucial and vital activism
that you do and that we're all learning
from which is your beauty brand
is one of my favorites it's just an
amazing beauty brand i
love it it's extraordinary your products
your packaging it's like my favorite i
was so excited to have you on the show
go to our website at the
drewberrymoreshart.com to
look more at sharon's important work in
beauty and
activism sharon thank you for coming on
this show i'm such a huge fan of yours
you